[Musique]
mieux tu en trouveras d'autres comme ça parmi
le changement parce que si tu pars chasser entre
les feuilles sur lesquelles tu marches habituellement
donc ça prend beaucoup de temps pour le trouver donc si
tu vas à notre souche Tu le feras probablement
trouve plus
[Musique]
Je jacu n'a pas d'estomac, il a une conversation
sa digestion est très rapide donc
dans sa conversation, il a mangé du café
il y a une autre graine qu'il a déjà mangée
aussi alors ces graines mélangées avec
le café fait absorber le café
caractéristiques de ce fruit la douceur
acidité ces fruits et entre dans
du grain de café
[Musique]
donc on récolte
en fonction du travail que nous avons
pour fabriquer les produits qu'il est
naturellement cher, il n'y a aucun moyen d'en fabriquer un
Le café Jacu est peu coûteux, vous savez ?
parce que la ligne Rarity là-bas
Incertitude quant à savoir si vous possédez ce produit
dépend beaucoup plus du Pas que du
Nous n'avons pas de catastrophe environnementale
Il n'y aura plus de café ici
[Musique]
l'histoire du café le processus de récolte
tout est très curieux, une sensation
merveilleuse connaissance que nous ne connaissons pas
je n'avais pas je ne savais pas
[Musique]